The Kengan match
can only be watched by selected members
and other authorized people.
It is held outside of the public eye.
The particular atmosphere
makes them so enthusiastic
that a huge amount of money is exchanged
in just a moment.
The next Kengan match will be
between GANDAI and Nogi Group.
VENUE: UNDERGROUND PARKING LOT
KIMURA SECURITIES BUILDING
Ohma Tokita,
the affiliated fighter for Nogi Group.
Chairman Nogi
and Ms. Akiyama are late.
The match could begin at any moment.
KAZUO YAMASHITA
NOGI PUBLICATIONS, NOGI GROUP
Well, I still can't believe it.
Ohma's opponent for today is--
On the other side is
the affiliated fighter for GANDAI.
Jun Sekibayashi!
Jun Sekibayashi, known as "Hell's Angel,"
from Super Japan Pro-Wrestling,
a major organization covering
every style from hardcore to standard.
As its unshakable champion,
he is a big name
in public combat sports.
Public combat sports versus
underground martial arts...
I can't miss such a big match!